[Music]
and welcome to Hannity and tonight we
are broadcasting live just north of
Atlanta Georgia in Alpharetta Georgia
where in just a moment we're going to
hear from the Republican governor of
Florida the Democratic governor of the
great state of California for what is
the first ever red state blue State
debate right here on the Fox News
Channel now we will do our best to give
equal time to each governor we will
limit answers to 60 seconds per question
we'll be a little flexible as needed let
the debate breathe as needed along with
a 30- second time for rebuttal let me
start by introducing both Florida
Governor Ronda santz California governor
Gavin Nome Governors uh thank you both
for being here really appreciate it
great to be with I know both of you
personally I've known you both for a
long time I know you're very busy um I
also know this I know that both of you
love your individual states I know you
both have a deep and Abiding Love for
our country as I do um but where we are
in the country we've never kind of been
this divided in a long time there are
clear and deep and profound differences
in your approach to governance and
before we begin one quick note to all of
you that are watching at home okay I'm
now the longest running Prime Time cable
host in the history of cable news I'm
now and I feel blessed in my 28th year
at Fox it's kind of widely known that I
am a conservative however tonight I will
be moderating this debate I will not be
part of the debate our questions tonight
will be coming from well sourced fact-
centered perspectives and you will see
and hear most of tonight's questions
will deal with the most fundamental
issues the ones that impact the lives of
the people that make this country great
the people in Florida the people in
California and in many ways every state
in the country will discuss taxes the
economy immigration crime guns
homelessness education parental rights
abortion gas prices in other words the
things that impact you every single day
in the end you will get to decide which
governing philosophy you believe is
better the governors will explain their
governing philosophy and again
fact-based questions so let's get
started everybody ready all right we uh
as we speak there is a phenomenon it is
playing out across the entire country
Americans they are leaving blue States
and droves in favor of red States you
can see numbers on the screen right now
from the years 2021 and 2022 these
particular numbers are Stark in the
state that you lead in the case of you
Governor Newsome according to the US
Census this is where the numbers come
from in 2021 2022 California's lost
750,000 residents to other states
Governor DeSantis during that same
two-year period you gained
44,000 residents from other states so
Governor Dan santis we had a coin toss I
was not part of it I missed it um but
apparently Governor Nome you won the
coin toss um and you chose to let
Governor DeSantis have the first
question you will get the last word
tonight uh so I begin with you you know
for governor Nome I will ask you know
what your response is on this as well
what do you it's a simple question how
do you explain this phenomenon what
governor what's going on when I was in
the Navy I got orders to go to Naval
Amphibious based Coronado and Southern
California and I was a Lifeline
Floridian but I went there and I was
like man this is one of the most
beautiful places on Earth and I think
California has more natural advantages
than any state in the country you almost
have to try to mess California up and
yeah that's what Gavin Nome has done
since he's been Governor he's the first
governor to ever lose population they
actually at one point ran out of U-Hauls
in the state of California because so
many people were leaving of course he's
imposed restrictions on his own people
while exempting him himself from those
restrictions and going to The French
Laundry while his people were suffering
he led the country in school closures
locking kids out of school while he had
his own kids in private school in person
now he's very good at spinning these
these Tails he's good at at being slick
and slippery he'll he'll tell a blizzard
of lies to be able to try to mass the
failures but the reality is they have
failed because of his leftist ideology
and the choice for America is this what
Biden inherit and Nome want to do is
take the California model and do that
nationally in Florida we showed that
conservative principles work this
country must choose Freedom over failure
Governor Nome your reaction well it's
good to be with you Sean it's nice also
to see in a a tie as well tonight good
to be with you uh Ron and I imagine I
dressed up for the occasion Governor
dressed up no I'm I'm impressed and I'm
grateful look uh it's an important
occasion this is an important
conversation and I think it's important
the folks watching they're probably
wondering what are we actually doing
here and and and I want to answer that
very directly I'll tell you why I'm here
I'm I'm here uh to tell the truth about
the Biden Harris record and also compare
and contrast Ronda sanz's record and the
Republican party's record as a point of
contrast that's as different as daylight
and darkness you want to bring us back
to a
pre-1960s world America in Reverse uh
you want to roll back hard-earned
National rights on voting rights on
civil rights and lgbtq rights on women's
rights not just access to abortion but
also access to contraception you want to
weaponized grievance you are focusing on
false separateness you in particular Ron
are on a Banning binge a cultural Purge
intimidating and humiliating people you
disagree with you and president Trump
are really trying to light democracy on
fire so Sean there are profound
differences tonight and I look forward
to engag them but there there's one
thing in closing that we have in common
is neither of us will be the nominee for
our party in 2024 Governor um great
opening statement
but it didn't address the issue can you
explain this migration out of California
and going to Red state state well hold
on you you mean the the last two years
more Floridians going to California than
Californians going to Florida I put up
on I put by the way that's going to be
fun to fact check so we'll just start
right there California has no peers uh
California dominates size of 21 State
populations combined it's the fifth
largest economy in the world we dominate
number one manufacturing State we
dominate in two-way trade and research
and development access to Innovation
more scientists more researchers more
Engineers more Nobel laurates in the
state of California than any other state
in the nation the finest system of
higher education it's the birthplace of
life science and biotech and
nanotechnology we dominate in Green Tech
we dominate in high-tech we dominate in
artificial intelligence so with respect
I think it's an interesting campaign
strategy for Ronda santis to be bashing
a state of 40 million Americans when
California simply has no peers well that
that's a pretty slick way of not
answering your question he went on a
binge of putting out a lot of leftwing
platitudes here's what I would say I I
talked to a lot of the people that have
moved from California to Florida and we
never used to get people from California
to Florida or really anywhere in these
because why would you leave California
it's got the best weather
excuse me sir so but one of the things
that I did I had was talking to a
gentleman a
couple I'm going to let the debate
breathe but it's his turn let's take
let's take turns so I was talking to a
fellow who had made the move from
California uh to Florida and he was
telling me that Florida is much better
governed uh safer better budget uh lower
taxes all this stuff and he was really
happy with the quality of life and then
he paused and he said oh by the way I'm
Gavin Newsome's father-in-law so we do
count
Gavin's in-laws as some of the people
that have fled California and come to
the State of Florida and why are we why
are we getting people to come we have a
50-year low in the crime rate you don't
see in the last 10 years we've had a 45%
decline in homelessness California has
had a 45% increase in homelessness we
back the blue I was walking the streets
of San Francisco a couple months ago and
I had some of the cops in San Francisco
do a beine to come over to me and I
didn't know what they were going to say
and they're like we want to thank you
for stand for law enforcement because we
don't get that support in the state of
California so people understand quality
of life matters they understand that
Florida's doing it right and I can tell
you the numbers speak for themselves we
have way more people moving to this
state than leaving Gavin can't say the
opposite more people are leaving
California then are moving into Cali
bring coming to California the other way
of L last two years but let's talk about
crime Governor hold Governor wait a
minute hold on a second said a lot of
things were factually untrue including
that 50y year crime law which his own
law enforcement team said should not be
using you you have yet to address the
issue but I asked you twice you don't
want to answer but the issue of why the
migration out of red States I'm sorry
out of blue States we just established
more florians coming to California in
the last over you had a net L establish
asserted it it's a fact no it's not a
fact moving on let's go hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else